the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
now today I need to get started by
finishing up what I did last time namely
talking about numerical methods and I
want to just carry out one example and
then I want to do one fill in one loose
end and we'll and then we'll talk about
the unit overall we were talking last
time about numerical integration I'm
going to illustrate this just with the
the simplest example that I can we're
going to look at the integral from 2 a 1
to 2 of DX over X which we know
perfectly well already is the log of X
evaluated between 1 & 2 which is log 2
minus log 1 which is just log 2 now if
you punch that into your calculator
you're going to get something like this
I hope I saved it here hmm yeah it's
about 0.6 9 what else uh 3 1 4 7 that's
more digits than we're going to get in
our discussion here anyway that's that's
about how big this this number is and
the numerical integration methods will
give you about as much accuracy as you
can get on the function itself and of
course some functions we may have more
trouble approximating but the function 1
over X we know pretty well how to do
because we know how to divide so since
since the function that we're
integrating here is 1 over X it's going
to be not too difficult to get some
arithmetic nevertheless I'm going to do
this in the simplest possible case
namely just with two intervals now you
really can't expect things to work so
well with two intervals that's a pretty
ridiculous approximation to your
function when you have two intervals
that means you're looking at the graph
of this hyperbola and you have one here
and you have two here and you have
three-halves and you're really only
keeping track of the values at these
three spots so the idea that you can
approximate the area just by knowing the
values of three places is a little bit
of a stretch of the imagination but
we're going to try it anyway now the
trapezoidal rule is the following
formula it's Delta x times 1/2 the first
value plus the second value plus 1/2 the
third value in this case it's the
pattern is 1/2 1 1 1 1 1 1/2 and in this
case Delta X is 1/2 because this
interval is length 1 right the B minus a
right let's just point that out here
here B is equal to 2 a is equal to 1 B
minus a is equal to 1 and the number n
is 2 and so Delta X which is B minus a
over N is 1/2 so here's here's what we
get and let's just see what this number
is
it's a half of the value at here well so
let's just check what these values are
this value is 1 this value over here is
2/3 and the last value is 1/2 all right
because the function of course was y
equals 1 over X and those were the three
values that we have so y 0 this one is y
0 this one is y1 and this one is y2
all right now here we have 1/2 times 1
plus 2/3 plus 1/2 times 1/2 now on an
exam I don't expect you to add up long
messes of numbers like this when you
have two numbers I expect you to add
them up if they're reasonable or
subtract them just as we do when we take
anti derivatives like for example I
don't want you to leave the answer to an
integration like this in this form I
want you to simplify it at least down to
here and of course don't expect you to
know the numerical approximation but I
certainly expect you to be able to to do
that on the other hand when the
arithmetic gets a little bit long
you can relax a little bit but I did
carry this out of my calculator unless I
mistake and it's about point point nine
six it's not it's pretty far off all
right so remember what it was it it's
it's it's what you get when you get
these straight lines and there are these
little extra pieces of junk there now
don't don't trust that too much but it's
but it's it's far the point is that it's
far off all right so now let's take a
look at Simpsons rule and I claim that
Simpsons rule is surprisingly accurate
in this case really even a little more
than it deserves to be the formula is
Delta x over 3 times y 0 plus 4 y 1 plus
y 2 so the pattern is 1 for 1 or 1/4 and
then it alternates twos and fours until
for one at the very end and if I just
plug in the numbers now what I get is
1/6 because Delta X is 1/2 again and the
value for y 0 was 1 and the value for y
1 was 2/3 and the value for y 2 is 1/2
so here's the the estimate in this case
and let's this one I did carry out
carefully and it came out to 0.6 9/4 for
four all right which is actually pretty
impressive if you think about it given
what what the logarithm is now what's
going on with Simpsons rule in general
is this
if you Simpsons - the exact answer an
absolute value is approximately of the
size of Delta X to the fourth power
that's really the way it behaves which
means that if Delta X is about 1/10 so
if we had divided this up into ten
intervals which we which we didn't but
if we divide it up into ten intervals
then you could expect that Delta X the
error would be about 10 to the minus
fourth in other words four digits of
accuracy here for this for this thing
but the the exact analysis that this is
a more careful analysis of is this is in
your text book and I'm not going to to
do it but I just want to point out that
it is an effective method it really does
give you nice four-digit with with
manageable you could even really do it
by hand it's it's so convenient the
Simpsons rule whereas the other rules
aren't really that impressive as far as
giving fairly accurate answers the the
other the last little remark to make is
that the reason is that Simpsons rule is
matching a parabola and somehow the
parabola follows this curve better it's
giving the exact answer so I'll mention
this Simpsons rule
is derived using the exact answer for
all degree two polynomials in other
words parabolas all parabolas and but
all even though all the ones of lower
degrees so straight lines would work and
constants would work as well whereas the
other ones only work for say straight
lines the trapezoidal rule only works
for four straight lines but there isn't
a weird accident it turns out that it
also works for cubics once you get the
formulas it works for cubics so it's
also exact for cubics and and that's
what explains the fourth order validity
the last thing that I want to point out
is that this is extremely vague what I
said there and you should be a little
bit cautious about it you need to watch
out for 1 over X for X near 0 all bets
are off if the function is singular and
there's a lot of area under there and
it's also true that if the derivative
messes up you're in trouble too you
really need for the function to be nice
and smooth in order for Simpsons rule to
work this is wothout that's a real
wothout but we'll try to watch out watch
out for whenever X near x equals 0 then
then then this thing doesn't work we
really this thing really depends on on
bounds on derivatives but I'm going to
be relatively vague about that I'm not
attempting to give you an error analysis
here ok so if you were doing this on an
exam how do you remember this strange
pattern of numbers well the one thing
that I want to remember
to you is as a way of remembering it so
the one mnemonic device will call the
mnemonic device here for remembering
what it is that you're doing is to
remind yourself of what happens for the
simplest possible case which is f of X
is equal to one it seems very modest but
if the if it doesn't give you the exact
answer for f of X equals one you've got
the wrong weightings
and here if you check out what happens
when in the first formula here y 0 over
2 + y 1 + well we'll go all the way to
yn minus 1 plus y n over 2 all right if
you check that formula out here this is
the trapezoidal rule if you check it out
for this case then what you get is that
this is equal to Delta x times what well
all of these are ones and how many are
there in the middle there are n minus 1
of them in the middle so it's 1/2 plus n
minus 1 plus 1/2 at the tail end so all
told it's Delta x times n and I remind
you that Delta X is equal to B minus a
over N so Delta F this thing is equal to
B minus a and that's just as it should
be what we just calculated is an
approximation to this integral here
which is just the area of the rectangle
of base B minus a and height 1 which of
course is B minus a so this is the this
is the check that you that you got your
weighted average correct here you've put
the correct weightings on everything and
you can do the same thing with Simpsons
rule and match up those those quantities
there was a question in the room at some
point did I all right no okay all right
fine so now the next thing that I want
to do for you is a the loose end which I
left hanging namely
I want to compute that mysterious
constant square root of PI over 2 this
is really one of the most famous
computations in in calculus and it's a
very very clever trick I certainly don't
expect you to to come up with this trick
I certainly wouldn't have myself but
it's a it's an important thing to
calculate and it's just very useful so
I'm going to tell you about it and it's
just on the method the subject that
we're dealing with in this unit namely
slicing or adding up so the first step
which is just something that we already
did was that we found the volume under
this under this this curve this
bell-shaped curve each of the minus R
squared but rotated around an axis ok
rotated around this axis around this way
all right so we figured that out and
that was a relatively short computation
I'm just going to remind you it goes by
shells we integrate the whole range from
0 to infinity and we have 2 pi R e to
the minus R squared D R so this again is
the circumference of the shell this is
the height of the shell and this is the
thickness of the shell circumference
height tickets
okay so we're just taking a little piece
here and sweeping it around and then
adding up and then this antiderivative
is a PI minus PI e to the minus R
squared evaluated at zero and infinity
and we work this out last time this is
this is PI it's pi times one minus zero
all right so the conclusion is that V is
equal to PI we already know that now the
problem that we want to deal with now is
the problem not of a volume but an area
and this looks quite different and of
course the answer is going to be
different but let's do it so this is
this question mark here and I'm going to
do the one for minus infinity to
infinity and I'll relate it to what we
talked about earlier in this in this
unit in just a couple of minutes when I
show you the the procedure that we're
going to follow here's the quantity and
now what this is interpreted as is the
area under this bell curve this time Q
is really an area
now what's going to turn out to happen
is is this this is the trick we're going
to compute V in a different way and
you'll see it laid out in just a second
we will compute V by slices we're going
to slice it like a piece of bread here
we're going to solve for that same thing
here and then amazingly what's going to
happen is that we will discover that V
is equal to Q squared that's going to be
what's going to come out and that's the
end of of the computation that we want
because actually we already know what V
is we don't want to read this equation
forward we want to read it the other way
we want to say Q squared is equal to V
which we already know is PI and so Q is
equal to the square root of pi all right
I haven't shown this yet all right this
is the this is the weird part and I'm
going to put it in a little box so that
we know that this is what we need to
check we need to check this fact here we
haven't done that yet now let me connect
this with what we did a few days ago
with what I called one of the important
functions of mathematics besides the the
ones you already know and so the
function that we were faced with and
that we discussed was this one all right
and then we were interested in the value
at infinity we were interested in this
which if you draw a picture of it and
you draw the same bell curve that's the
area under half of it that's the area
starting from 0 and going to
that's the area under half so this chunk
is f of infinity and now I hope that
this part of the connection is not meant
to be fancy that the idea here is that
that Q is equal to twice f of infinity
this number here and so f of infinity is
equal to the square root of pi over 2 if
we if we believe what we said on the
last panel and that was the thing that I
drew a picture of on the board namely
the graph of F looked like this and
there was this asymptote which was the
limit f of X tends to square root of pi
over 2 as X goes to infinity that was
that limiting value which is f of
infinity all right so this is the
asymptote and and now I've explained the
connection between what we claimed
before which was quite mysterious and
what we're actually going to be able to
check now
concretely by making this computation
okay so so how in the world can you get
something like this what's in that
orange box there that V is equal to Q
squared again the technique is to use
slices here and I'm going to have to
draw you a 3d picture to visualize the
slice so let's let's do that I'm going
to draw three axes now because we're now
going to be in three-dimensional space
and I want you to imagine the x axis is
coming out of the blackboard
the y axis is horizontal and there's a
new axis which I'll call the z axis
which is going up so what's happening
here is that I'm thinking of this this
is if you like some kind of side view
and this is a view where I've tilted
things a little bit up to the top now
the distribution or you could think of
this target in the plane where the most
likely places to hit we're in the middle
and it died off as we went down now I
want to draw a picture of this graph I'm
going to draw a picture of e to the
minus R squared and it's basically a
hump so I'm going to take the first the
slice along y equals zero the y equals
zero slice and I claim that that goes up
like this and then comes back down and
let me shade this in so that you can see
what kind of a slice this is this is
supposed to be along this vertical plane
here just coming out of the blackboard
and coming towards you and that's a
slice now I'm going to draw one more
slice so that you can see what's
happening I'm going to draw a slice at
another place along here this will be y
equals B some other level and now I'm
going to show you what happens what
happens is that the hump goes dies down
a little bit so the bump is just a
little bit lower and it's going to look
a little bit the same way but it's just
going to be a bit smaller
there's another slice here like that and
I want to give a name to these slices
I'm going to call this a of B that is
the area of the B slice under under the
curve under under the the surface okay
yes question yeah the solid yeah we're
trying to figure out this volume year
which is the one we started out with by
slices so first I have to think I'm
going to visualize so here I didn't even
visualize that I took a cross-section
and I thought about how to spin it
around without actually doing that in
three-dimensional space but now I'm
going to take a different kind of slice
I'm going to take that same bump which
is a three dimensional object I'm going
to lay it down on a plane which looks
like this and then it's a bump here
alright it's a hump and now I'm going to
try to slice it by various planes
yeah so one way of defining the bump as
you just suggested is you take this
curve and you rotate it around this this
z axis so in other words you make this
the axis of rotation you spin it around
that's correct so that shows you that
the peaks as you go down
here are going to are going to descend
the same way but I don't want to draw
those lines I want you to imagine just
what the slices parallel slices are
because I don't want to get cross slices
I want all slices parallel to the same
thing okay this is this is this is not
particularly easy to visualize now now
here's the formula for volume by slices
the formula for volume by slices is that
you add up the areas of the slices
that's how you do it you take each slice
you add the cross-sectional area and
then you take a little thickness dy and
then you add all of them up now because
this is extending over the whole plane
we're going to have to go from all the
way from minus infinity to plus infinity
and this is the this is this the formula
for for volumes by slicing
and now our goal in order to do this
calculation we're going to just fix a y
is equal to some B we're just going to
fix one of these slices and we're going
to calculate a FB that's what we need to
do in order to make this this procedure
to succeed now this is the only place
where this method works it's but it's an
important one in order to make it work
I'm going to have to again draw the plot
from a different point of view I'm going
to do the top of you so I want to look
down on this this XY plane here this is
the X direction and here's the y
direction and then again I want to draw
my slice my slice is here at y equals B
so it's just right on we're just right
on top of it and it's coming up at some
kind of bump here with a little higher
in the middle and going down on the
sides now the formula for the height is
this if I take a distance R here the
formula for the height of the bump is e
to the minus R squared
okay I'll store that over here e to the
minus R squared is the height at this
place if this distance to the origin is
R that's true all the way around and in
terms of B and X that we can figure out
that by this right triangle this height
is B and this distance is X so R squared
is equal to B squared plus x squared
question
like
- that's why I'm announcing our within
right
okay then question is is that the
excellent light so the answer is that
over here I cleverly use the letter R I
didn't I avoided using Y's and Z's or
anything and over here this is the
distance R and if you like this is Z
going up that's the way to that's the
way to think of it so that all the
letters are consistent I just avoided
giving it a name that's good that's
exactly the point
all right so now I claim I have a
formula for R squared and so I can write
this down this is e to the minus b
squared plus x squared but now I'm going
to use the rule of exponents which is
that this is the same as e to the minus
V squared times e to the minus x squared
and that's going to be our the main way
in which we use the particular function
that we're that we're dealing with here
that's that's really the main step
amazingly ok so now I get to compute
what a of B is
a of B is the area under a curve so it's
going to be let me write it over here
a of B is the area under this curve here
which is some constant time so if you
imagine call this thing the name C under
some curve e to the C times e to the
minus x squared where the c is equal to
e to the minus b squared that's what our
slices in fact it looks like one of
those it looks like one of those bumps
here is its formula again it's the
integral from minus infinity to infinity
of e to the minus b squared e to the
minus x squared DX i just recopy what i
had up there and this is the height at
each value of x with be fixed and now
the two so we have a lot of steps here
but each of them is very elementary the
first one was just that the law of
exponents that we could split the two
into products now I'm going to make that
splitting even further this is a
constant it's not varying with X so I'm
going to factor it out of the integral
this is e to the minus b squared times
the integral from minus infinity to
infinity of e to the minus x squared DX
so this might look frightening but
actually it's just the property of an
integral all integrals have this kind of
property you can always factor out a
constant and now here comes the
remarkable thing this is e to the minus
b squared times a number which is now
familiar to us what is this number this
is what we're looking for this is our
unknown q
so I've computed a of B and now I'm
ready to finish the problem off a of B
is e to the minus B squared times Q Q is
that strange number which we don't know
yet what it is so now I'm going to
compute the whole volume the whole
volume remember it's over there it's
minus infinity to infinity a of Y dy and
now I'm just going to plug in the
formula that we found for a now I'm
doing this for each B so I'm doing it
varying over all B so I have integral
from minus infinity to infinity and here
I have e to the minus y squared I've
replaced B by Y and now I have Q and I
have dy I just recopy what I had over
there into the formula for slicing and
now I'm going to do this trick of
factoring out the constant a second time
this is a constant it doesn't depend on
Y it's the same for all Y it just will
factor out this is the same as Q times
the integral from minus infinity to
infinity e to the minus y squared dy and
now lo and behold this expression here
of course notice how I define Q let's go
back carefully to where Q is defined
here's Q this T is a dummy variable it
doesn't matter what I call it I can call
it X I can call it you i can call it V
in this case I've given it two different
names at this stage I called it X and at
this stage I'm calling it Y but it's the
same variable and so this little chunk
is Q and altogether I have two of them
for Q squared being the total and that's
that's the end that's the end of the
argument
it's a real miracle yeah
well great great question the question
is wait a minute as Y changes doesn't
exchange and then so then this wouldn't
be a constant all right so that's the
way in which we've used the letters X
and Y in this whole course when you get
to 1802 you'll almost never do that
always why an X will be different
variables and they won't have to depend
on each other now let me show you where
on this picture the X and the y are
we've got a whole XY plane and here I'm
fixing y equals B why isn't varying
where as X is changing so in other words
I don't have a relationship between x
and y unless I fix it in this case I've
decided that Y is going to be constant
for all X over here I made a computation
and I have a q which is just a single
number no matter which B I took it
didn't matter which no matter which y
equals B of course I changed the name to
beat so that it wouldn't be so jarring
to you but in fact this V was y all
along it's just that the x varied
completely independently of the Y I
could fix the Y and vary the X I could
fix the X and vary the Y so there it's
it's a different use of the letters from
what you're used to
it happens that Y is not a function of X
in this case yes
yes
the the question is because I'm rotating
around the z-axis doesn't exchange
exactly as much as Y does what happens
is that x and y are symmetric variables
they they can be treated equally but if
I decide to take slices with respect to
Y being fixed and X varying then of
course they they're they're now
separated and I have a separate role for
the X and a separate role for the Y
right alright if I'd sliced it the other
way would have gotten the same answer I
just would have reversed the roles of X
and Y so what's happening is that x and
y are on equal footing with each other
in this in this picture and I could have
sliced the other way I would have gotten
the same answer that that's more or less
the answer to your question ok all right
now I have given you a review sheet and
I want to run through briefly what's
going to be on the exam and this set of
a list of exam questions is what's going
to be on the exam
there are sorry this is not displayed
correctly so exam questions but now I'm
just going to show you what they are
there are five questions on the exam
they're completely parallel to what you
get on what you got last last year so
you should look at that test it's worth
looking at and you'll see in the
descriptions on this sheet that the that
the that what I'm describing is what's
on that test so what's going to happen
is and this is also posted on the web is
that you'll be expected to calculate
some definite integrals using the
fundamental theorem of calculus do a
numerical approximation there will be a
Riemann sum a trapezoidal rule and
Simpsons rule calculate areas and
volumes and then some other cumulative
sum either an average value or
probability or perhaps work and sketch a
function which is given in this in this
form as as an integral right so those
are those are they those are the
questions and and and and you'll you'll
see by the example of last year's exam
exactly the style they're really going
to be very similar yes question okay
good question
so the question is for reline subs
what's the difference between upper and
lower and right and left so here we have
a Riemann sum and I'm going to give you
a picture which is maybe this function y
equals 1 over X which is the one that we
were discussing earlier if you take the
function y equals 1 over X and you break
it up into pieces here however it
doesn't matter how many pieces let's
just say there are 4 of them then the
lower Riemann sum is the staircase which
fits underneath so this one is a picture
of the lower subtle it's always less and
in the case of a decreasing function
it's going to be so since if you like
since 1 over X decreases the lower sum
equals the writes up
you can see that visually on this
picture the the values you're going to
select are going to be the right ends of
the rectangles the upper sum is the left
one now if the function wiegel's up and
down then you have to pick whichever
side is appropriate or maybe it'll be a
point in the middle if the maximum is
achieved in the middle yes another
question
[Music]
correct if the skiff did function is
increasing then the lower sum is the
left sum so it just exactly reverses
what's here so so this is decreasing
lower sum is right handsome increasing
lower sum is left handsome is that yes
right so there's a good question so the
question is suppose you're faced with a
function like this in this last problem
which generally these are the trickiest
problems and the question is how are you
ever going to be able to decide on an
asymptote even whether there is an
absolute tote and the the answer is
you're not it's going to be pretty
tricky to get keep track of what's
happening is these goes to infinity we
had an example on the homework where it
was oscillating and it's very unclear
what's what's going on you have to do a
very long analysis for that so in fact
you know just don't worry about that now
at the very end of the class we'll talk
a little bit about these asymptotes and
really the first issue is whether they
exist or not and that's that's even
something that's a serious question
which we'll address at the very end of
this course that's right it's not going
to be anything that complicated all
right other questions we have we still
have a five whole minutes and I have an
example to give if nobody has a question
yeah
the question will I tell you which one
what to use when I tell you the
numerical approximation as you'll see on
the exam that practice exams you have I
will ask you for all three I will ask
you for the lien on some the trapezoidal
rule and the simpson's rule I'm
guaranteeing you they'll all three be on
the exam I'm guaranteed that every
single thing which is on that piece of
paper is on the exam and you'll see it
on the on the exam that you've got it's
exactly parallel so what's there what
about areas of value which methods user
community yeah so so with with areas and
volumes the question is will I tell you
which method to use all right so let's
let's discuss that
so with areas and volumes there's
there's basically so this is always true
with areas and it's true with volumes of
revolution you by the way you should you
should read this sheet not everything
that's on here is is have I said but I
but but you should read it because it's
all relevant so with volumes of
revolution you always work your way back
to some 2d diagram so there's some
there's some 2d diagram which is always
two-dimensional diagram which is always
connected with these these problems I
mean something this hard is is really
just too hard to do on an exam right I'm
not going to ask you something that's
complicated on an exam because this
involves a three-dimensional
visualization but once you're down to 2d
you're supposed to be able to handle it
now what's the main issue after you've
got your two degree to 2d diagram the
main issue is do you want to integrate
with respect to DX or dy and the answer
is that you will it will depend and if
there's one that's going to cause you
incredible difficulty and I feel that
you're not able to dodge it then I might
give you a hint and say you better use
shells or you better use disks or
washers or something like that but if I
feel that you're grown-up enough to
figure out which one it is because one
of them is so ridiculous you say forget
it
immediately after thinking about it then
I won't tell you which one because I
figure in other words I don't want you
to waste your tongue but I'm willing to
waste a minute or two of your time on a
on a on a wild-goose chase all right so
let me give you an example of this
suppose you're looking at the curve Y
between 0 and X minus X cubed all right
so this is some kind of lump like this
it goes from 0 to 1 because the right
hand side is 0 at at 0 and 1 here it's
some kind of thing and there are these
two possibilities one of them is to do
shells and then you would youwould so
this is supposed to be rotated around
the around the y axis in this case and
the same would apply actually to the
area problem so I'm doing a slightly
more complicated problem but you could
ask for the area underneath this and so
forth ok so we can integrate this DX or
we can integrate this dy this indicates
that I'm deciding that this is going to
be a thickness DX and I'm integrating DX
so that's a choice that I'm making now
the minute I made that choice I know
that these are shells because they sweep
around this way and that makes them
shells cylindrical shells and if I do
that the setup is this it's 2 pi X times
X minus X cubed DX now I claim that when
you get to this point you already know
you've won because this is an easy
integral to calculate so this is so
you're done here you're happy all right
now if you happen to be say oh gee I
hate to do this I want to do something
clever you could try to do it with
cutting this way all right sorry let's
let's do this all right and this would
be the dy thickness and then when you
sweep this around you get what we call a
washer
which is really just the difference of
two disks all right so the shape here is
is this thing swept Oh swing around this
axis and it looks like this so it's
going to be the difference of radii so
what's the what's the formula for this
it's some integral of pi times the right
end which I'll call X 2 and here the
left end which I'll call X 1 so this is
PI X 2 squared minus X 1 squared dy all
right now already at this stage you
think to yourself this is more
complicated than the other method ok so
you've already abandoned it but I'm just
going to go one step further into this
one to see what what it is that's
happening if you fake try to figure out
what these values x1 and x2 are that
corresponds to solving for X 1 and X 2
in terms of Y so that's the following
equation X 1 and X 2 will solve the
equation that the curve x minus x cubed
is equal to Y all right now look at this
equation that's the equation X cubed
sorry
yeah X cubed minus x plus y I guess
let's see yeah that's right is equal to
0 this is a cubic equation
although there is a formula for this
you've never been taught the formula for
this equation so therefore you will
never ever be able to get a formula for
X 2 and X 1 as a function of Y and
you'll never be able to compute this one
this is more than just a dead end it's
like crash burn and you know
self-destruct so you know there may be
such a thing so do the other way good
luck folks